[Music]
I've met your dad a couple of times he
he's a terrific stage manager and I've
been a guest on a few shows and done a
few things that he's worked on and so we
always chat and I really like him a lot
I'm wondering what's all this like for
him your success your insane meteoric
success for him he just he must be very
proud
oh he loves it he's a total Fame [ __ ]
he does wear a shirt that says I'm
Kristen Stewart's partner basically he
really does giannis you go anywhere even
if I'm not with him he's like hey I'm
Jon Stewart father of Kristen you do
happen to have you ever seen Twilight
yeah well that's my kid Jared weren't an
airplane lower your voice my mom
literally when I had first couple years
I was on TV would go to supermarket the
supermarket and she would go through and
she'd say things she'd say to the
cashier like you like television no no I
kind of like it's alright you like Conan
I don't know kind of you can go to at
all
that's a tropical bird that I was doing
I know you recently quit smoking oh how
how tough is that been for you are you
doing the patch are you chewing a lot of
gum what are you doing to help you quit
smoking I think I was I was a bit of a
faker it was a circumstantial smoker
cigarettes would just sort of fall into
your mouth
yeah no you mean you didn't smoke that
often it was just occasionally no I just
feel like I wasn't addicted to nicotine
as I wanted something in my mouth just
remind me of the Sarah Silverman show
last week
[Applause]
[Music]
why did I do that why don't you do that
I don't know I'm glad you did I'm glad
for the Internet you did say that I love
the Internet
everything I love the internet too
[Applause]
it's a problem I found out something
very interesting about you which is you
like to as an actor you need to psych
yourself up sometimes for an intense
scene and you have kind of an unusual
technique or maybe it's not unusual but
there's certain there's a certain video
that you like to watch speaking of the
internet there's a certain video that
you like to check out that you inspires
you tell us what this video is he's a
phenomenal actor and I just um
the intensity levels I've never been
able to reach and so I I sort of I
watched it repeatedly and know that I
could never really amount to what he's
achieved and it's just it's inspiring
and it's generally it just keeps me
going so I figured we'd show people okay
this is funny cuz when I first heard
this I thought okay this is like the
most intense scene Marlon Brando's ever
done and then I find out that I don't
even think this kids an actor if he is
he's a genius but it's a YouTube video
and if he isn't I'm really sorry yeah if
he isn't an actor he's yeah well let's
take a look okay my mom just canceled my
brother's Warcraft account and use
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how psyched is that kid that you watch
him before you do an intense scene
that's pretty amazing
[Laughter]